ah
it's beautiful i remember cooking my
first brisket like it was 16 years ago
it was pretty terrible for the first
brisket in my backyard to 106 briskets
every day
i'm also still learning and i want to
share these things with you
[Music]
oh my this looks really nice
so i'm going to teach you exactly like i
would train someone
at franklin barbecue but i've never
really gotten to do
this level of detail that's what i'm
looking for on airflow
that smoke is really really important
that's where that flavor is coming from
fire is really fun to watch
[Music]
we're going to learn how to build fires
we're going to learn how to maintain
fires
we're going to cook a pork butt we're
going to pull it steamy pork butts
guys with glasses gee whiz we're gonna
cook some ribs
and i'm gonna show you guys how to cook
a brisket from start to finish
really get down to the details of how to
trim how to wrap it
and then at the end slicing it that's
very well done i'm proud of this whole
thing i should find some people to eat
this
sharpie in a perfect world this brisket
would take me 12 hours
2 55. 9 o'clock start to ramp up 280. i
work in five degree increments
have a plan be ready to make mistakes
but also document your mistakes
i really like to keep it super simple
kosher salt
and 16 mesh black pepper
watch that movie cocktail a few times
it's almost like a typewriter going back
and forth
there's a lot of wiggle room in this
stuff learn the basics but
you only learn how to make good barbecue
by making bad barbecue
my favorite part about barbecue might
actually not be eating it
it's the process and how we get there
you cook with your heart pour your heart
and soul into this thing and then at the
end share that with people
that's really the art of barbecue in a
lot of ways i'm aaron franklin
and this is my master class
you